[Music]
we are back
with seth in the slc salt lake city
what's up seth
how's it going john dude we are rocking
onto the break of dawn this morning how
about you very good i'm i'm very good
dude i just got back from salt lake city
what a beautiful beautiful city i was
there a couple of times this month
i didn't even stop by and say hi we did
i hung out you were too
busy whatever playing video games
whatever hey that is a beautiful city
stunning yeah
yeah there's a lot to like about it it's
just i i mean
you're more than welcome to visit more
often john
well thank you they asked me to leave
but i appreciate you i'm just kidding
they didn't necessarily i just the more
i travel the more this country is so big
and so beautiful and there's so many
awesome people it just it's incredible
but great community there man so what's
up brother how can i help
so i have two sons one of them is two
years almost two years old the other one
is four my older one has kind of been my
shadow his whole life um anytime i'm off
work he's with me my younger son i just
don't have that same connection with him
and i i don't i don't know how to how do
i make room for one without pulling away
from the other one
that's a great question man
so have you tried this and you felt like
you were pulling away from one tell me
about that
yeah so this so this is going to sound
um crazy right have you ever heard this
show before
uh yeah yeah we're all crazy it's cool
so what's up so i was i was sitting um
on the floor with my younger son we were
reading a book together and everything
was fine when my older son came up and
sat down my younger son just like got up
and walked away but then he turned back
and looked at me
like almost like i had betrayed him does
that make sense
like yeah he doesn't feel like there's
space for him and it kind of broke my
heart yes yes absolutely
um
oh there's so much there
so much there
you know who broke your heart
you know
not your two-year-old
don't give your two-year-old that kind
of power
no i don't okay here's why they're two
and there's a reason why as a society
we've been like you know what we
shouldn't let two-year-olds buy beer not
a good idea
and uh we shouldn't let two-year-olds
drive or operate heavy machinery or
smoke marijuana like there's a whole
bunch of things we've said two-year-olds
can't do but we give them access to our
souls
and they say things like i don't like
you daddy and it destroys us
or they they give a look to us and we
interpret that look as
you betrayed me father
i'll remember this
and i will kill you in your sleep you
scoundrel i mean like we say this crap
to ourselves so duh but hey i do it too
man i do it too i told my wife that i uh
i'll be careful i tell us i told my wife
the other day
like literally our daughter doesn't like
me
and she looked at me like i was she's
like yes she does you're annoying
and she doesn't like to be around
annoying but she really likes you
and my wife was right so all that to say
is this man
i'm just smiling so big because i've
been right where you are
where i feel like that
you betrayed me father i i felt that so
bad give me give me another time give me
another time
well
he
the younger one
as long as it's just him and i he's
totally fine with kind of playing right
but then any time my older son comes up
and wants to play around as well he just
kind of
goes away like he doesn't want to stay
and play with the two of us me and my
older son and i'm sorry as a three you
know he doesn't want to play his three
he wants to play kind of one on one and
him and his brother have a great
relationship
but it just to me
the only way i can describe it is to he
he just doesn't feel like he has space
if my older son is there
and i would say that you're putting a
lot of
words into his head
that's true lots of thoughts and
feelings and emotions
it may just be things are loud
it may be that dad acts different when
brother shows up
and i i for whatever reason your kid
feels uncomfortable about that
but articulating there's just not enough
space for me here that's a lot to put in
the head of a two-year-old
so i it probably actually goes back to
one of my biggest fears about having a
second kid was that i wouldn't be able
to
uh
you know the relationship just with my
second is so much different from my
first because i already have a first yes
one of my one of my great friends man
he's one of the greatest men i've ever
met his name's brad he's awesome guy and
i remember
man he was one of the first one of our
little gang to have kids and his
daughter man he loved that girl he was
incredible dad just awesome dad
and
they were talking about having a second
kid and i'd never forget he mentioned to
me it had never occurred to me until he
said it
i don't understand how i could possibly
love somebody as much as i love this my
daughter
and so i don't know that i won't have a
second kid because that wouldn't be fair
because there's no way it competes with
this
and so what i would tell you is that
same fear that you're expressing there
you put it out into the world and now
you're looking for it everywhere where
am i not adding up where am i not loving
enough where am i not doing this right
you hear what i'm saying
yeah yeah i
this is not how i expected this you're
right
well i want i want you to flip this
whole thing around
you're gonna love these kids differently
and you're gonna love these kids a lot
and my daughter needs different types of
connection and interaction than my son
does
my son loves to hug
my daughter loves fighting i don't
understand it but it is
awesome
it's just so different like i will come
home from work and my like i'll say hey
come here hank and he'll come over and
we'll hug i just it's a good 15 30
second hug
and then i will set my backpack down and
my daughter will square up with me
and she'll say are you ready and she's
five i'm like i get i guess we're gonna
have our welcome home fist fight here we
go you know what i mean
it's just this chaotic
like a hurricane of hair and
hands
and it's awesome and then we hug and
then it goes our kid we're going to love
him differently
and so here's two things we can do
the first thing is this
ask yourself honestly am i annoyed by my
my younger son
does he annoy me
do i feel bothered by him
those are the feelings that i want you
to root out
and those aren't things he's doing to
you that's not the fundamental
attribution error when you get in his
head and you pretend you know what he's
thinking and why he's doing things you
can't do that
get inside your own head and say it
actually kind of annoys me when he comes
around
or
he he just doesn't play like my other
kid does i want you to root those things
out because your young son will feel
that he'll absorb that stuff
and i want you to be honest about how do
i connect with my kid and this is the
pot talking to the kettle here brother
because i'm learning this in real time
right now
how do i connect with each one of my
kids and how do i give each one of my
kids their own time
and
they've got to learn to play with one
another and me at the same time because
we're gonna have lots of family trips
we're gonna have lots of times and we're
all going hunting together and we're all
going fishing and we have times when
we're all going to go
play family or play house or whatever it
is we're going to do there
um but it's what's both and
and if your son
decides when your other son shows up
that he doesn't want to participate
i want you to
grab his two-year-old little hands
and say
daddy would love it if you stayed and
played with us
daddy wants you to be a part of this
it's more fun for us to play when you're
with us
and then he's free to go if he wants to
so i don't want him to ever leave
without a
hey i want you to know that we would
have more fun if you were here
and i don't want him to feel forced
trapped into a situation that for
whatever reason he doesn't want to be a
part of right now
and i would s
for the best you can
don't overthink an interaction with a
two-year-old
[Laughter]
don't let me rephrase let me rephrase
that
two-year-olds are brilliant and
intuitive
and so if a kid doesn't feel safe and
they walk away be it be attuned to that
don't over intellectualize a
two-year-old how about that
okay
don't have academic conversations with
somebody who is less than 36 months old
lean into the things that he loves
invite your four-year-old into those
things and let your four-year-old do
things that maybe are different are your
boys way different from each other
yes yeah yeah
yeah so give him some private
connection time
and then some days say hey we're all
gonna color because it may just be when
the four-year-old brother comes we all
end up playing soccer and the
two-year-old just wants a color
or the two-year-old wants to play soccer
and the four-year-old like all soccer
balls go away we just saw color so be
attuned to those kind of things but just
be intentional about last time we played
this today we're going to play this
and if your four-year-old throws a fit
and says well i'm not doing that
you do the same thing with him i'd love
it if you were here it's more fun to
color when you're with us
but if you want to go play feel free
and they're going to learn autonomy and
what they're going to learn is oh i'm
making the choice to leave this
situation dad's not kicking me out of
here
i like it that sound good
yes thank you very much you're a
just john brother just john and
you're a good dad man
i wish every
couple of little boys had an old man
like you who was just trying to
love them the best he knew how good for
you man good for you
we don't let two-year-olds buy
cigarettes
we don't let them hurt our feelings
one in the same